when thinking about creating a community
I want you to think about why someone
would want to join your community what
are the reasons people join communities
is because they enjoy it if people are
internally motivated you'll see more
long-term sustainable relationships made
there is also the goal of creating a
community that has a good balance
between people enjoying or having fun in
your community but also getting news out
of it let's hear from amir and tell e.on
other tips on how to engage with your
community so a community is a group of
people who share the same mission or
passion and have the same goal one to us
to achieve the same goal community could
be anything from a physical community
that people come and meet and talk about
something all the way to an online
community and we see a lot of these
happening lately so first of all you
need to understand what is the need what
is the mission community is a part as a
group of the mission so if you have a
mission that needs the community that
needs the scale then that's a good hint
if that you need a community it's it's
also really a way for you to achieve
something so think about what do I want
to achieve and if I can use other
people's passion to to get what I want
to achieve just know that it needs to be
a joint passion right you need to work
with them towards a joint goal so first
of all you need to be very engaged with
them they're volunteers they're
passionate about what you're trying to
solve but you always need to engage be
transparent tell them I you found this
bug we're fixing it make make them feel
that they're a part of the process in
order to build a value for your
community you need to come up with three
things which I think are very important
for every member of the community growth
fun and belonging so if we analyze what
are the aspects of your community that
contribute to the members growth fun and
belonging these are the three things
that will create the value for your
members and maintain them not every
startup needs an online community many
startups are just about a user
interaction right
is an amazing app but it doesn't need a
community it has interaction which is
simple and intuitive and does not
require community there are other
startups lately that really rely on a
community to be successful sometimes
they rely on two communities to be
successful and it's really important and
it provides you with a scale that you
don't have if you don't have this
community so a lot of the startups that
need social interaction a lot of the
marketplaces these are types of stirrups
that really need a community when you
want to cede interaction when you have
interaction embedded into the app that
requires a lot of people so good
examples for companies that need
community are uber for example a
community of drivers a messenger would
be a good a good example Google of
course we have a big community of a
Google developer community a place where
you have a marketplace would be a good
example so a good way to get people to
join a community is have a good goal if
the goal would be I want to make money
for myself that's probably not go where
you can get a lot of people to join you
right but getting people educated all
over the world is an amazing goal and
you can really get people inspired and
very engage with this type of goal
community of one person or two people is
probably boring and it's not really a
community you need to have critical mass
in order to start a community there is a
process called seeding where you have a
call to action or you hack into other
communities to seed your own community
so think of it there's many ways to
create to do the seating of the
community one of the things would be to
go to another community and say hey guys
we're opening a new community why don't
you join us another way is to go through
social channels and talk about your
passion about the mission and get people
excited about them I've seen startups
that just have a coffee and talk about
certain topic before they even start a
community they just say hey guys if
you're interested in this topic come to
Mission Street in San Francisco have
some coffee with us and
talk about this once you get people
excited and engaged you can create
online community or an offline community
out of that the way to grow a community
from a small community of a big
community is to think about the value
for the for the members right how can
the creating a bigger community at will
add more value to the to the members
some people call it the k-factor the
virality you need to think about what
incentives are there for people inside
the community to add more people to the
community right what is the incentive
what's in it for them to grow the
community some communities don't feel
like drawing right some communities say
hey I want to keep my community size
small because I know everybody here and
that could be amazing right a lot of our
google developer communities are small
because of that right they don't want
10,000 people and which they don't know
but if you want to grow and you if you
want to scale you'll need to build
incentives to get people excited about
growing in the community okay I think
the key things with running a good
community is treating your community
well-being communicative transparent
having a joint mission that is
passionate for you and passionate for
the community keep fostering a community
make sure that you maintain the
community that people don't drop off big
mistakes that i see startups do is they
create a community but they don't invest
in the community so i think investing in
the community is very very important
take the fun very seriously take the
growth very seriously take the belonging
very seriously and always think of how
do i invest in these and how do i
maintain my community a community is
something very very precious and if you
don't invest in it it will die and
getting the community the second time is
like getting someone to fall in love
with you the second time it's really
really hard so invest in it and continue
and maintain your community so when I
join develop relations in Google I was
tasked to create Google developer
communities these are communities of
developers that meet our on a monthly or
quarterly basis to talk about technology
so the first thing I did was to source
community leader
so I I came and I tried to find good
speakers or people are passionate about
communities and just say hey I'm
starting this community the path the
mission is to empower people through
technology do you want to join me most
of them said no some of them said yes
those are those who wanted to actually
work with me and to create this
community join me and we just had coffee
and we talked about how do we create the
community so they start creating their
own community but the key was to
maintain them right to keep them
passionate so I every month I just went
to like the best restaurant I could find
in the area gather them together and we
just talked about cool stuff so I
created a meta community of my community
leaders they felt that they're empowered
they felt that there are amongst people
who are very very passionate about these
things and they feel that they belong so
I actually managed to get them excited
about building communities for me yeah
so community management I think first
and foremost it's about really
understanding your users and what they
need and how to connect them in ways
that are meaningful to them so for us
you know a lot of it was understanding
that we need a moderator in every
community so we went and did that or
understanding that we needed very
specific guidelines because this is a
community it's about sharing and people
get confused about what is sharing what
isn't sharing what kind of things can
you share and we kind of learned that
from from our community and from our
users as they were doing these things
sometimes we thought all this is okay
but then we got left back from the
community saying that actually offended
me so kind of learned it over time and
you define the guidelines and we
realized that it's very necessary to
have community guidelines that that's
kind of explain exactly why and once you
have those people will will will respect
that and abide by that so if they do
something that's kind of wrong and you
kind of tell oh it's in the guideline so
they're like okay and they're not
offended by it the role of a moderator
is just making sure that everybody
sticks by the guidelines so if they try
to post something that's irrelevant or
not family friendly or or not sharing
related they will just you know moderate
that content
out and explain to the user that because
a lot of times it's not intentional
right the user was just genuinely
thinking that they could use this
platform for this so they just want to
see the explanation and be referred to
the guidelines